Toutes et tous, nous avons une certaine vision
de la réalité qui nous entoure.
Cette manière de voir les objets de notre
quotidien est partagée socialement.
Notre entourage, notre famille et nos amis
ont souvent une vision très proche.
D’autres individus dans d’autres groupes,
à d’autres époques ou dans d’autres
cultures auront une autre vision, concurrente
à la nôtre.
Par exemple, l’école est perçue par certains
certaines comme un espace de socialisation,
d’autres un lieu de transmission et d’apprentissage,
une partie la considère comme un espace de
confrontation voire de torture.
Chacun, chacune, en fonction de son histoire
et de sa socialisation et donc de son appartenance
sociale aura une façon de considérer l’école,
plus ou moins proche de celle d’autres personnes
ou d’autres groupes.
En sciences sociales, ces manières de voir
les choses sont appelées des Représentations
sociales.
Je m’appelle Sylvain Dramaix, je suis professeur
de sciences sociales dans le secondaire supérieur
en Belgique et dans cette vidéo, je vous
explique ce que sont, les caractéristiques
et les fonctions des représentations sociales.
Définition
Une représentation sociale est une construction
intellectuelle collective qui donne du sens
au monde dans lequel nous vivons et qui nous
permet d’agir sur celui-ci, dans celui-ci.
Ces représentations sont un mode de connaissance
pratique du réel qui s’oppose par exemple
à la connaissance scientifique.
Les représentations sont un concept très
important des sciences sociales et en particulier
de la psychologie sociale.
En effet, nos représentations sont à la
base de la quasi majorité de nos actions
et de nos pensées.
Elles sont le moteur de nos comportements.
Les représentations sociales ne sont pas
des opinions qui sont beaucoup plus individuelles
et moins stables.
Les représentations étant données qu’elles
sont construites et partagées par les membres
d’un même groupe voire d’une même société
sont plus stables plus intériorisées que
des opinions qui sont plus individuelles et
conscientisées.
De ce fait, alors que nous avons conscience
de nos opinions, nous ne sommes pas toujours
en mesure de dire ce que sont nos représentations.
Caractéristiques
Comme elles sont partagées par les membres
d’un même groupe ou d’une même catégorie
sociale voire d’une même (“société”),
on dit qu’elles sont sociales.
Etant donné que les personnes que l’on
côtoie et qui participent à notre socialisation
font partie du/des même(s) groupe(s) et de
la même société, nos représentations nous
paraissent évidentes et naturelles, on dira
qu’elles sont normatives.
Elles définissent une norme.
De plus, comme elles dépendent des groupes
et des sociétés auxquels les individus appartiennent,
elles sont toujours relatives.
Les représentations sociales sont construites
à partir d’une partie seulement des éléments
de la réalité, on dit qu’elles sont partielles.
Inconsciemment, nous excluons les faits qui
ne correspondent pas à nos représentations
et nous retenons les éléments qui les confirment.
Elles résistent donc assez bien aux apprentissages
même si elles sont contredites par des faits
totalement objectivables.
Les groupes sociaux, les catégories sociales
et les sociétés ne sélectionnent pas forcément
les mêmes éléments pour construire leur
représentation.
Il y a un parti pris, on dit qu’elles sont
partiales.
Fonctions
Globalement, les représentations sociales
nous permettent d’interagir et d’agir
avec les autres à moindre coût cognitif
c’est-à-dire rapidement et facilement.
De manière détaillée, nous retiendrons
4 fonctions remplies par les représentations
sociales:
Fonction de savoir
Par leur fonction de savoir, les représentations
nous permettent de comprendre et d’expliquer
la réalité.
Les représentations sociales donnent du sens
au réel et aux expériences que nous vivons.
Elles permettent entre autres de créer des
catégories, de conceptualiser de manière
spontannée, afin de pouvoir lire le réel.
Par exemple, certains groupes peuvent se représenter
l’économie comme un gâteau à se partager
(contrairement à ce qu’en disent les économistes
qui voient plutôt des flux).
Dès lors l’arrivée d’immigrés dans
une économie peut être à l’origine d’opinions
négatives à leur égard parce qu’elles
sont construites sur cette représentation
de l’économie comme un gâteau.
Si vous rencontrez une personne couchée sur
le sol dans une tenue négligée, vos représentations
vous conduiront peut-être à considérer
qu’il s’agit d’une personne sans domicile
fixe assoupie ou ivre morte et la situation
vous semblera “normale” si l’on peut
dire.
Vous trouverez du sens à cette réalité.
Par contre, vous serez un peu perplexe si
une personne très soignée en tailleur ou
en complet 3 pièces est dans la même position.
Dans ce cas, vos représentations ne vous
conduiront pas à penser que la personne est
assoupie ou ivre et vous en conclurez qu’elle
est peut-être victime d’un malaise.
Fonction d’identité
Les représentations sociales font partie
d’un ensemble d’éléments qui participent
à l’existence d’une identité commune
et d’une conscience collective.
C’est la fonction d’identité.
Par exemple, les élèves d’une même classe
se représentent l’école et certains profs
d’une certaine manière.
Peut-être qu’ils partagent des plaisanteries
sur eux que d’autres ne comprendraient pas.
Cela renforce la cohésion du groupe et participe
à la construction d’une identité commune
du groupe-classe.
Fonction d’orientation
La fonction d’orientation est un « système
d’anticipation des attentes ». Les représentations
sociales permettent de supposer ce qui va
se passer et donc d’agir en conséquence.
Elles orientent nos actions.
Par exemple, quand des amis proposent d’aller
boire un verre ou d’aller faire du shopping,
on a une bonne idée du type d’activité
jusque dans ses détails comme les lieux dans
lesquels on va se rendre, la durée de l’activité,
l’attitude à adopter, la tenue vestimentaire
à respecter.
Cela est permis par une représentation commune
au groupe d’amis de ce qu’est boire un
verre ou faire du shopping.
De ce fait, les représentations permettent
aussi de communiquer facilement et d’agir
collectivement.
Dans sa fonction d’orientation, les représentations
interviennent donc avant l’action.
Fonction de justification
Elles peuvent intervenir après l’action,
il s’agit alors de la fonction de justification.
La fonction de justification permet à l’individu
de légitimer (càd rendre acceptable) ses
décisions, actions et conduites à l’égard
de ses pairs, mais aussi envers d’autres
groupes sociaux.
Dans certaines régions, les habitations sont
toujours fermées à clé.
Dans d’autres (comme aux Pays-Bas), les
personnes n’hésitent pas à laisser leur
porte ouverte.
Cette différence de pratique s’explique
en partie par des représentations différentes
du voisinage, d’un côté il est perçu
comme hostile et pas de l’autre.
“Je n’oserais pas partir de la maison
en ne fermant pas la porte à clé, avec tout
ce qu’on entend…” s’oppose à “Il
fait très calme ici, on connaît les voisins,
on peut laisser sans problème la porte ouverte”.
Un autre exemple est le maintien de l’ouverture
des écoles lors de la crise sanitaire.
C’est parce qu’elles apparaissent comme
des lieux de socialisation et d’apprentissage
à la grande majorité des individus que les
politiques ont justifié leurs décisions.
Il est par contre peu probable que si des
représentations autres avaient été majoritaires
comme l’école perçue en lieu de souffrance
ou de classement social, les politiques n’auraient
pas justifié leur décision de la même manière
et ils auraient de toutes façons sans doute
pris d’autres décisions vu la fonction
d’orientation.
Il arrive que les élèves rencontrent des
difficultés à bien distinguer les différentes
fonctions.
Cela est tout à fait normal car ces différentes
fonctions sont liées les unes ou autres et
sont parfois difficilement discernables étant
très imbriquées.
Cette vidéo est terminée.
Je vous invite à consulter le descriptif
pour plus de ressources comme la fiche de
cours et toutes les références à la base
de cet exposé.
Je vous invite à vous abonner si vous avez
apprécié cette vidéo.
Je vous souhaite beaucoup de joie dans la
découverte des sciences sociales et je vous
dis à très bientôt dans une nouvelle vidéo.